the first batch of the most recent US
sanctions against Russia come into force
today they focus on exports of
american-made electronics used in the
aircraft and space industries Moscow
says the despite that it's not going to
affect ordinary people however in
November Moscow could face a second wave
of restrictions described by the US
State Department official as more
draconian this is what they could bring
them may include more limits on trade
and banking and cuts to diplomatic
relations as well the measures of the
consideration may also ban Russia's
state airline from entering US airspace
well Washington says the new sanctions
are in response to the poisoning of the
Russian double agent at his daughter in
Britain in March this year the
investigation into that case still
ongoing and no hard evidence of Russia's
involvement has been provided Moscow has
slammed these sanctions now as
slow-witted saying they're based on a
false pretext as usual Washington
provided no evidence of justification
while only throwing out of vicious
innuendos it seems they are following
the principle worse is better we will
counter the United States slow-witted
blinkered and aggressive approach with
sober-minded orderly work on a
constructive agenda it seems
Washington's gripped with sanctions
favor these days there's been numerous
debates in the US Capitol on how best to
punish Russia on Capitol Hill it was all
about sanctions three high-profile
events subtle differences but the main
thrust in all of them was punished
Russia the UK Foreign Secretary even
flew into town to make his case those
who don't share our values need to know
that there will always be a serious
price to pay if red lines are crossed
and today the United Kingdom asks its
allies to go further by calling on the
European Union to ensure its sanctions
against Russia are comprehensive and
that we truly stand shoulder-to-shoulder
with the u.s. two different hearings on
Capitol Hill about Russia's supposed
malign actions now the two things named
our US election meddling and the
poisoning in Britain of Sergey and Yulia
scree Paul with Nova choc now no proof
has ever been presented ongoing efforts
to interfere in our sacrosanct election
processes and those of our allies are
just some of the unacceptable behaviors
of the Putin regime Putin wants to break
apart the American Republic Russia's
attempts to interfere in the 2016 US
presidential election are well and
widely known Russia has undertaken a
campaign of malign activities in its
attempt to compete with us our allies
and our partners and cats at 2:31 gives
us more tools with which to respond now
all the voices agree that Russia has
never yielded in the face of sanctions
in the past however they say that the
answer is more sanctions just because
they can the bread and brazenness of
Russia's malign conduct demands a firm
and vigorous response our actions are
imposing an unprecedented level of
financial pressure on those supporting
the Kremlin's malign agenda and on key
sectors of the Russian economy
now the second round of sanctions is due
to be imposed in November why well
everyone knows that Russia will meddle
in the upcoming midterm elections the
same people
spinning spurious narratives about
meddling in the past are now predicting
the future when we talk about Russian
interference it's not just past
elections that we're worried about
clearly the Russians know that the u.s.
is on guard at this point they were
successful to a degree in 2016 we think
that they're adopting those as they're
looking at new ways to divide Americans
is there any concrete plan in place for
addressing the threat that's actually
posed by Russia and our intelligence
agency stopped them from doing it again
now some members of Congress are calling
for paper ballots to make sure the vote
is transparent and it's not digitally
hacked Americans need paper ballots
marked by hand until that system is
adopted every election that goes by is
yet another election that foreign
governments hostile foreign governments
including Russia can hack but why bother
Russia could probably hack papers and
pencils
Kalib Maupin RT New York the whole thing
is quite a conundrum for me why they
continue to you try to politicize this
issue and use sanctions in some way to
help them domestically except that
they're trying to cover up their own
shortcomings their own shortchanging of
the American people and to try the blame
our divisions in our economic crisis in
our racial divide year on and on an
outside power on which is the oldest
trick in the book going back to the
beginning of civilization if the
Democrats lose or do not do as well as
they hope in the November election
having used Russia again as their as
their main talking point they may have
to readjust and realize that the
progressive wing of the party is growing
and that the American people don't give
a damn about Russia and that they have
to finally address the real issues here
and leave this Russia issue alone and
get back to normal relations with this
country that isn't that is imperative
for for world peace essentially
you